claude tu rentres de new york c'est quoi
la boîte qui marche en ce moment il ya
un club qui vient d'ouvrir la semaine
dernière qu'israël m qui est certain
c'est où
c'est 28e rue appelée c'est à dire en
plein dixième temps il ya le tendre
devient la mode complètement tous les
envois s'ouvre dans ce qu'on a c'est un
des gars de noël c'était le décorateur
in health qui a ouvert sa alors le décor
est sublime c'est comme une grande
maison il m'a traité âge il ya la
bibliothèque un billard il ya la chambre
à coucher avec le lit et baltanas il ya
plus de ceux dossevi petit seau d'eau
d'appartements à chaque pièce une grande
salle de bal ça n'appartient et le tance
flore est complètement les sous sols
dans une île de pied et des prisons
ouais très marrant moi vraiment sublime
mais alors ce qui m'a surpris c'est que
ça faisait trois cadeaux ce calvaire
j'ai pas trouvé d'ici peu la vie new
yorkaise je crois qu'on ait la tête très
près car l'essor ils sortent moins calme
au regard de tous sans peur de leurs on
les a perdus et 10 ont peur l'alcool je
suis arrivé le premier jour il avait
cité la mise en vigueur de la nuit mon
cigarette dans les lieux publiques ou
dans les boîtes on peut fumer dans les
boîtes encore on peut fumer mais ça va
arriver où cela va arriver aussi arrivés
ils ont peur du crack
ouais ils ont peur je te dis night
lights en ce moment mais par contre ils
font des très bons endroits
ouais le mt alors mg kg et le neige
marche toujours mais bon la clavicule en
droit c'est plus le droit de tout des
way robin fresu as voit cerner ce taux
ouais on est fous dernier st parce
qu'avant c'était cela qui fait des
bulles à onnaing tél
on a des flashs comme ça ouais par
moments des cons rencontre un jeune
artiste qui le branche on a fait une
expo avec ernesto alors je peux dire que
à part pardo ernesto le deuxième point
qui a exposé ici qui a tout vendu
ouais ça a été encore deux tableaux de
ville ça a été un succès
vraiment dans tous les domaines j'ai
fait plein de thunes alors et nous tous
marchander les mots très forts à ça tu
trouves un marchand avait sèchement je
m'occupe de ça c'est vrai un succès
vraiment tous les domaines et les gens
vraiment remarqué son expo je suis dit
là presque tout vendu et je comprends
son succès parce que c'est vraiment une
paire nature nouvelle intemporel je peux
la mettre dans l'ancien avec andy
moderne dans tout ça va ça va dans tout
et je crois que les restos dans quelques
années on en parlera beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup c'est la star qui monte alors
je pense oui je pense que c'est vraiment
une année les gens soient tous des
jeunes des anciens les connaisseurs en
peinture des caylar ça s'explique pas un
tel twitter où tu l'as pas là seulement
de l'arrivée il a le plus de coeur il
avait passé quand j'ai pas failli à ma
réputation c'est ça coûte combien
tableau d'un restaurant où il fera dix
mille francs ce qui est accessible par
rohmer qui sont passés ici moi
l'équivalent du championnat il y en a eu
toutes sortes se faire une expo tous les
mois ils vont tous les goûts et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou